as an independent filmmaker it means
everything in the world to be part of
presenting Charles Burnett with non re
Oscar he's a true hero of the cinematic
arts whose work continues to inspire and
influence I'm I'm very aware that in
speaking about someone who has battled
against cliches in all his films I'm
resorting to one when I say that in
regards to Charles Burnett's work the
cream rises it can sometimes take years
sometimes decades but eventually the
best will stand the test of time and
rise to the top it has taken 40 years
for killer of sheep to become
acknowledged the acknowledged
masterpiece that it is today it kept
rising steadily until it demanded our
attention some of the resistance comes
from the fact that it's not an easy film
for example there is no conventional
three-act structure but Charles knows
that life doesn't have a three-act
structure and nor should a film about
life killer of sheep is a lyrical
portrait of a community on the margins
the film doesn't ask us to feel sorry
for its characters to pity them but it
does demand that we afford them dignity
and respect this demand comes as a
whisper not a shout it comes by allowing
the audience to spend quality time with
the film's characters the quiet everyday
moments the time in-between I first
became aware of Charles Burnett's work
when I was a film student at NYU
Charles was telling stories of the
working class and using first-time
actors and shooting on location I found
this particular approach the
storytelling and craft which was very
similar to that used by the italian
neorealists deeply inspiring and right
now there is a new wave of American
filmmakers from all backgrounds who
regard their work as a political and
social act this wave of artistic
activism can be directly traced back to
Burnett's groundbreaking debut in
speaking about his lead character Stan
Charles has said that Stan's real
problems lie within the family trying to
make that work and be a better and be a
human being you don't necessarily win
battles you survive well tonight Charles
not only has survived his battles he is
one the cream has risen thank you so
much sir for your incredible work
[Applause]